Sports Illustrated lays off most of its
staff after AI Scandal and money
troubles its parent company has fired
more than 100 employees it's kind of
wild to see that apparently their their
parent company missed a payment for the
rights to use the the brand and now the
company is laying off tons of people
they've owned the magazines in 2019 sold
the publishing rights sorry ABG owned
the rights to uh they sold the rights to
Arena Group which is amassed substantial
debt and missed a recent $3.75 million
payment for the rights and this is the
end you know what man it's kind of sad
but also my my question is should we be
happy about it right Bud Light is on the
verge of death they're saying there's
going to be a strike potentially in
March there will be no beer because the
employees are upset they want more money
budlight can't give them more money
because nobody's buying Bud Light and
you know what's really fascinating we
actually we we on this show discussed
this the understanding that uh the
Cascade failure effect of a major brand
bud bu light may make a billion dollars
you stop buying Bud Light and what
happens is the cost per can goes up so
uh let's let's start from the very
beginning we have a cast Brew Coffee we
sell ground and whole bean coffee we
wanted to sell cans of cold brew to sell
at the volume we can afford it would
cost $5 per can to have a can of cast
Brew cold brew coffee that no one's
going to buy that I mean that's a
ridiculous thing to like buy a can of
coffee for five bucks you need to get
down to like $2 or you know $220 which
means if we were to sell maybe like 2
million cans then we would make I don't
know 10 grand off that sale and that's
enough profit generated to cover the
cost of all the employees if we lost
$50,000 in sales of 2 million cans now
we are not breaking even anymore the
whole thing just collapses that's what's
happening to Bud Light when I see Bud
Light failing everybody's cheering but
part of me is like hey maybe this is
what the woke left wants Sports
Illustrated gets woke goes broke and now
we're all like haha you get what you
deserve for all I the woke left is like
we've destroyed a legacy brand there was
there was a dad who handed a Sports
Illustrated to his kid it's talking
about football and his favorite ath like
look this is when so and so first got on
the team it was something I remember now
it's like what are what are you going to
remember from your childhood that you're
going to be able to hand down I don't
think we should be celebrating these
Legacy Brands getting woken blowing up
no because it's like it's it's a culture
Revolution this ideology is parasitic
and it will destroy whatever it takes
over if it it will take it'll you know
infest it or it'll invade it'll take
over it'll wear whatever it takes over
like a skin suit and if it destroys it
totally it's fine it does it's
completely completely it's completely
fine with
destroying uh whatever it is that it
gets into whether it be uh you know
video games or whether it be you know uh
the sports or or whatever it doesn't
matter what it is whether religion the
the whole liberation theology all that
stuff is all Marxist influence and stuff
it'll get into
whatever it is that you're whatever you
know uh institution you're talking about
and then it'll either assimilate it or
it'll destroy it everybody's cheering
for the destruction of budlight because
budlight did the Dylan Mia thing and I'm
like okay totally get it but understand
I mean when was bud when was Bud Light
Budweiser has been around for a really
really long time someone want to Google
when Bud Light came out I don't think we
I I think we should celebrate when we
defeat wokeness but I think we have to
be careful if we C celebrate how the
woke sabotaged and destroyed 1982 as Bud
Budweiser Light and then reintroduced 84
as Bud Light so I don't I don't care too
much about budlight in that kind like
it's been around since the ' 80s okay
fine but but with Sports Illustrated and
with other Publications I think I think
it would be important for us to
recognize if the the the the goal of
wokeness in the culture Revolution may
be we don't care if we own it or it's
destroyed so long as we own it or it's
destroyed exactly 100% that's that's
that is the entire goal of the of the
cultural revolution they need to take
over what the things that Americans come
together over so whether it be like
whether it be bu light as a brand or you
look at what they do to Disney Disney
was a wholesome family American brand
and now Disney's reeling with half the
country hating Disney and half the
country loving Disney and and there's
all kinds of strife that's that kind of
stuff is what this ideology does it
can't do anything but the the it can't
do anything but destroy the whole thing
is called constructing they they got us
cheering for the destruction of our
institutions yes well terrifying we
should not do that we should not destroy
things and that's why like we talked
about about whether or not we should
like you know make room for people that
realize that that they had you know been
consumed by bad ideas whether it be woke
or whatever you want to call it and you
have to make way make a space for people
to come back in you have to make it okay
for people to come back be like yeah I
think maybe I was kind of wrong on that
stuff you can't mock them you can't make
fun of them you can't you know be like
no and shun them and stuff because we
it's it's an illiberal ideology that's
infected them if they want to move
beyond that and come back to Liberal
principled stances then we should we
should welcome her yeah I think um one
of the goals of this ideology assume
that it's like a communist attempt to
disrupt would be to get half of like
your friends to turn on you and be like
no you're not woke enough you got to be
woke and then 5 years later they come
back and they're like I'm sorry but then
for you to not forgive them would be a
victory for the like this communist
thing like you've got to forgive these
people when they realized that they were
played yeah it's I mean it's I think
it's weird though how like the AI thing
like how how long ago was that that that
story came out was a couple months ago I
don't know anything about it what is it
so a bunch of uh journalists uh they
were fake journalists like they'd have
fake profile pictures and fake names or
whatever and they were just like you
know they' you'd read the article and it
would make no sense they're all AI
generated articles and they'd publish it
as if they were real journalists on the
site and then like somebody you know ran
it through an AI Checker and also like
could clearly see that these weren't
real people and stuff and you know
published a piece on it this is Sports
Illustrated yeah oh yeah and then like I
think that was a couple months ago and
then so it it seems in here that like
they didn't you know pay the licensing
fee or whatever so it's kind of weird
how like you know that came right after
that if it was kind of planned like uh
to do that like to take down the brand
or I'm not sure but it's it's like
certainly weird that those two events
you know coincided like they couldn't
afford to pay writers so they used AI
they couldn't AFF to pay licensing so
they just didn't that's possible that
the brand I never really understood
Sports Illustrated as a brand or as a
product I remember in the 80s and 90s
like it was a magazine about sports but
I had TV at that point so like watching
pictures of a dude like this is in no
way exciting watching a guy throw the
ball that's cool and you may be sitting
in the back of a car or on a plane or a
train or waiting in a Lobby and like it
was like it was about reading like
sports stats I guess but then when the
internet came out because they would
they would they would like go and like
have journals like sit down with like
the people that were they s you sit down
with coaches and players and owners of
teams and all that all of the inside
stuff you were getting with Sports
Illustrated it wasn't just like hey
these guys beat these guys on this day
you know it was like all the stuff that
goes into it you and then the internet
came out and was like the great leveling
and uh it just became one of like a
thousand periodicals that do that kind
of thing and I remember the Sports
Illustrated uh swimsuit issue was always
a big deal that's like the only time
every year anyone we even talk about
Sports Illustrated in my crew we weren't
like huge huge athletes um I I think
it's inevitable that uh periodicals the
people that rely on print I don't know
if Sports illustrators still rely on
print or if they have an online
subscription model but these things are
all the way of the dodo they're they're
extinct they they've gone Obsolete and
maybe if if the power all goes out and
we're back to like trading cards in the
dark then maybe books and novels and
magazines will become relevant again but
when you can check it all for free on
the internet these things have no place
anymore they need to adapt their their
business model it sounds like this
company didn't do that I don't know if
they even I mean I assume Sports
Illustrated had a website I mean I
haven't gone to look but um yeah yeah I
think it was like the online version um
of the Sports Illustrated stuff that was
all yeah I'm looking at it now it's
futurism I think was the publication uh
they had like this guy Drew Hernandez as
the or Drew Hernandez Drew Ortiz as the
author no we like Drew I know as the
author's biography it says Drew has
spent much of his life outdoors and is
excited to guide you through his
NeverEnding list of the best products to
keep you from falling The Perils of
nature it read uh nowadays there is
rarely a weekend that goes down goes by
where Drew is not out camping hiking or
just back on his parents Farm like all
this like random stuff because he was
not a real person yeah and like the the
profile picture is just some like AI
generated like person and these are like
the biographies of stuff and then they
reached out and uh Sports illustrator
deleted like all of the Articles and
stuff we were talking last night about
uh the Galaxy S 24 I'm not going to buy
it by the way I bought it you did I
bought it um well I want I want to see
what it's all about I want to see the
extent to which reality is being ripped
from our from our
faces dude it's going to be crazy thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 800m and become a
member over at timcast.net